So Donald Trump's chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
horrible guy, just a terrible
person, went on CNN yesterday,
was interviewed by Jake Tapper and Straightup
said we're not going to control the pandemic.
All hell has broken loose. Although if you've
been paying attention, we're eight or nine months
in. Of course, they're not going to control the
pandemic. That's obvious at this point. You just
wouldn't imagine that Mark Meadows would straight
up say it. Check out this is we call him the
Marcellus Wonder Mark Meadows, because he's known
for walking around every Trump rally with no mask,
hugging people, touching people, high five people.
He says we're not going to control the pandemic.
So here's what we have to do. We're not going to
control the pandemic. We are going to control the
fact that we get vaccines, therapeutics and other
mitigate. Why are we going to areas? Because it is
a contagious virus, just like the flu. But why not
make efforts to contain it? Well, we are making
efforts to contain it by running all over the
country, not wearing a mask. That's what the vice
president is getting back, back and forth. Let
let me just say this is what we need to do is make
sure that we have the proper mitigation factors,
whether it's therapies or vaccines or treatments.
Now, of course, we don't have those things that
Mark Meadows says we should have. But also,
Mark Meadows is wrong. It can be contained. Look
at the places that have contained it. Taiwan,
South Korea, Japan, Slovakia, Bangladesh, with
a very low death rate. Australia, of course,
with a very low death rate. We know it can be
done in countries of buried geographical size
and varied population size because they've done
it. Listen to Jake Tapper here as we continue
having to treat Mark Meadows like a little kid
to make sure that people don't die from this.
But to suggest that we're going to actually
quarantine all of America and knock down our and
saying, well, that they are. Joe Biden saying that
he says, lock everybody down. We're going to have
we're going to have a guard. We're going to have
a dark winter. We're going to have a dark, doesn't
it? Health officials say that's what health
officials say. It's one way worse. No. We asked
Joe Biden, hey, Jake, let's be honest. Glenn's
Friday and Saturday, let's be honest here, that
the health officials did not say dark winter.
Those were Joe Biden's words. When we look at
a health official. I think he was quoting William
Haseltine. Well, when we look when we look at the
number of cases increasing, what we have to do
is make sure that we fight it with therapeutics
and vaccines, take proper medication factors in
terms of social distancing and mask when we can.
So Mark Meadows there again, listing things we
should do that they are not doing. But again,
anybody looking at the trend lines sees a
dark winter coming. Look at the chart of
cases in the United States. I'll describe
it. I've marked the first two spikes.
And look at the trend line we have. The first
red arrow here points to spike number one, where
we got the 35000 cases a day. Then the numbers
backed off a little bit. The second arrow is Spike
number two in July. Seventy five thousand cases
a day. And now we already had a record eighty one
thousand and seventy nine thousand cases per
day on Friday and Saturday. And the trend line
is going to the moon. If this were a stock chart
of a stock you owned, you'd be getting ready to
make it. Ton of money because it looks like it's
going to the moon. Sadly, this is not a stock
chart. This is Corona virus cases. Next, Mark
Meadows tries to go after Joe Biden hilariously.
And when we when we look at this,
what we're going to defeat it, Jake,
because what we are we're Americans. We do that.
And this president is leading. While Joe Biden
is sitting there suggesting that we're going
to mandate massive debt, is holding rallies all
that's great for the country? That's correct.
We're leaving our masks required. No doubt
we will have already been, according to health
officials, contact tracing. There have already
been cases of individuals in Minnesota and
in Washington, D.C. and in Oklahoma that
got the virus at these Trump rallies that Dr.
Foushee himself called a super spreader event.
The one about why. That's also that, Jake. That
does not lead, albeit also being contact tracing.
Imagine saying Biden is the problem because
he wants a mask mandate, which, by the way,
is not something a president can do unilaterally.
This often isn't discussed, but a presidential
mask mandate. But by everything I've read from
left and right wing constitutional scholars,
a presidential mask mandate would be one of two
things. Either the president asks all 50 governors
to do a mask mandate in which David states rights,
in which case it states rights. It's 50 governors
saying, let's do this, or Congress would have to
pass something through the ability of the federal
government to regulate commerce in states. Those
are the two ways. So the idea of a unilateral
presidential mask mandate is really a fantasy
idea, quite frankly. Understand what it really
means. But again, the fact that people are having
this argument. We have a situation where people
are arguing about the freedom to give the virus
to other people. That's essentially what it is.
Freedom, freedom to do whatever the hell
I want, regardless of the consequences.
And then they have to go to what Joe Biden might
do after the chief of staff says we're not going
to control the virus. This should be an Abidin ad
immediately. Mark Meadows plainly saying we're not
going to control the pandemic. We know, Mark.
We know. We're going to take a quick break.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram at
David Pakman show. See what I was up to this
weekend. Follow me on Instagram at Davidge. Got
tak The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.